And then finally, we have the dictionary now it is a dictionary.
That will that can allow us to build.
more elaborative structures
We can actually use dictionaries to create binary trees
and graphs and we'll look at an example of that a shortly.
but a dictionary
it is mutable. You can add to it can remove from it.
It has keys but keys.
must be
defined
with two pools and lists you
the programmer do not have to type in the keys with dictionaries you
do.
And this has an special advantage.
So how do we create dictionaries and when we when we want to well?
associate
keys with the elements in a way that makes sense. So one example
we can do is airports.
Okay, so like sets dictionaries are indicated with
curly brackets.
So let's say you have the code
for an airport.
And you want to know to watch to which airport that
below that belongs.
So for example in Dubai, we have the XP.
Which corresponds Dubai International?
Now this is not so bad. But there are some airport codes that don't
even match the name.
Another one is let's say JFK even this one
is not so bad. So, this is John F Kennedy.
What about the one from Canada Canadian airports?
I think they have unusual name. What's the
what's the airport code for the main airport in Toronto? Why
YZ?
And the name of the airport is Toronto Pearson.
So a dictionary makes certain situations like this when you
see something like that.
And you don't have another, you know know the value.
And you can even go the other way around. So let's say, you know the name of the airport, but
you're not know it's code.
so we can
you can alternate.
And the way you would access a dictionary is the same as you
would access a two-pole or an index you type
in the name of the variable.
Open a pair of square brackets, but here instead of typing it
index like a number you will type in the corresponding keys.
So if you want Toronto Airport, you would type in why why
is the other string?